we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
i have to tell you i don't really
understand this caller i'm going to play
this for you maybe we can figure it out
together
yes this is doc from augusta
david i was horrified i don't know
what's up with the audio by the way i
i'm aware of it
at your comments about uh
that
clip you paid you you played with with
comments about
farts
and mask wearing
i just really blew me away and left me
wondering
what you spend your spare time
researching
i can only hope that in the future you
don't have a clip
where somebody claims that mass cannot
prevent
homosexual intercourse
come on david
later
anybody have any idea what that's about
like i don't even know what segment it
relates to because
we talk about masks and
i don't know it's a very very strange
voicemail if anybody has even the
slightest inkling what that might be
about please let me know
on today's bonus show we will be talking
about hurricane ida which hit
the gulf coast as a
category four storm
cash shortages at atms
gas shortages you can't get cash to buy
gas that isn't there anyway to get out
people in
dire dire circumstances um in louisiana
and elsewhere we will discuss that
reports of cheating at colleges
have exploded during the pandemic part
of it is sort of intuitive
if there's a lot of work from home and
test from home stuff happening
it's easier to cheat
but is there something else to it
uh psychologically going on making
people more willing to cheat during
covid we will talk about that on today's
bonus show and then lastly many of you
requesting this story
and when the people ask for it i will
oblige
um
disgraced
right wing darling milo yiannopoulos
not only has covid
but apparently has been injecting
himself
with um
a dosage of ivermectin meant for
livestock and even looking at the
picture of the syringe that milo posted
it looks like a pretty wide gauge
syringe
that
it it doesn't look like that thin
covered vaccine syringe i don't know how
many a needle rather i don't know how
many of you have seen
i i know many of you have you've gotten
vaccinated if you didn't look away when
you were getting the covet vaccine the
needle is incredibly thin so notably
it's it's almost a perfect needle i
would say
um the the needle that uh
milo posted
is quite a thick gauge and i don't know
what the hell is going on but we're
going to talk about the latest with milo
and ivor mekhton and his covid and just
whether he's trying to use this to mount
another comeback i actually recently
engaged i had a very very brief email
back and forth with milo a few months
ago before he got covered i will talk a
little bit about that and then we will
also talk about
the what we believe is the resolution to
last week's tech issues i have some
updates on that i got some very
important suggestions from people in the
audience so that's all today on the
bonus show i want to remind you we may
be as little as 24 hours
from reaching one billion youtube views
on our youtube on our main youtube
channel one billion youtube views
uh it is an incredible milestone in a
sense it's more impressive than a
million subscribers and i will talk
about why once we reach the milestone we
have a beautiful video plan that
producer pat put together for us along
with help from noaa and and it's it's a
great video we've got ready it's it's
it's queued up and ready to go when we
get to that billion and we will also
have a fantastic membership special go
out to our newsletter subscribers
when we get to that billion views so
make sure you're signed up at
davidpakman.com but before any of that
today's bonus show join me there i will
see you then